the Joe Rogan experience is George done
like what is he doing
how often is he trained all the time all
the time Sheen dude I'm telling you I
believe matter Kobe gets injured like
really I don't know I don't want to talk
for George but man he can he can kill
anybody he can kill anybody this man
he's the world's greatest martial artist
really I think so telling he's a monster
like I was training with him Saturday
the guy's an animal
well you know what when he came back and
fought Bisping I was like man this is
gonna be interesting to say and he came
back and he looked [ __ ] better than
ever
mmm his hands look great his cakes look
perfect and everything and that rear
naked choke was one of the best rear
naked choke Stu win a title I've ever
seen in my life yes it wasn't this one
with the paw on the back of the head it
was cinch yeah it was mmm rock solid in
his jujitsu looks so [ __ ] sharp man
yeah it's like it he clearly showed that
he had been training the whole time that
even though he hadn't fought in those
years he had been training hard he
looked better
he loves to Train like Saturday he
trained he finished all his rounds then
he was coaching some blue belts and
purple belts and just kind of hanging
out with them talking technique the guy
loves this stuff man he's just but
that's why I tell people she would love
something with him you'll do a lot of
thinking he's such a nutcase George he
always tells me like so many crazy
characters in MMA I'm like yeah my good
bro you're the crazy one of oh no I'm
not most aliens are stealing oh my god
dude
I assure room with him many times he
puts a foam roller against the door like
this why does he do that my George white
like I moved it you know I put her legs
right no bro leave it there like for
what in case the aliens get us he'll
know the next day he'll know because the
foam roller was moved
oh Jesus Christ does he think aliens who
come through walls how they taking him
out that she's take him through the
hallway holding his hand because they
wipe his memory after but he'll know
because they don't know he put the foam
roller there so when they move it when
they move it you'll remember it's a cue
for him to remember not what if he's
right what if they have assurance
parenting what if they really come down
they said this is their world's greatest
martial artist we are going to run tests
on him he's also but I don't know what
to say about he's a mind and he's got to
be like 37 now right he's older
is he 38 38 938 does he have like a
thought in mind of like when he's gonna
definitely like throw it in or just it
has to be in my opinion is gonna have to
be on wanna talk for him okay but I
think the thing that's gonna motivate
him is a mega fight right like he
doesn't want to be champion again and
fight every 3-4 months like that's done
right that's not gonna happen no more
but one mega fight invite him back for a
mega fight see if you could entice him
because he's a competitor man he's still
training he's stolen
ripped shredded fighting he could do
five rounds I mean like let me not do
five rounds right away but he needs a
few weeks then he's doing five rounds
like he's close to being like he can get
in fights eight he's there you know he's
just a monster man I'm talking like he's
he's a very young 38 year old like I
would if you I would tell you he's 20
years old really yeah he's my guy
could've [ __ ] oh my god he kidding me
he's a monster
that's crazy that he kept the dis a lot
of the guys they stopped fighting and
they just lose that discipline they just
don't want to train anymore
he loves well that's what's important
about George is that he's a martial
artist he's always been a martial artist
you know and that that desire to learn
and that the enjoying the training and
the struggle mm-hmm yeah you know it to
him it's it's it's happening for me too
when I go in the UFC taunt him why don't
you say Josh we gotta fight for you bud
[Applause]